>> Tucker: TRACE GAGGER, THANKS
FOR THAT.
AN INTERESTING NEW POLL FROM
SIENNA COLLEGE SHOWS THAT
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ HAS
WASTED NO TIME IN BECOMING
UNPOPULAR AMONG HER HOMETOWN
VOTERS.
A WHOPPING 44% DID NOT LIKE HER.
HOW DID SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN IN
CONGRESS ONLY A FEW MONTHS TURN
OFF SO MANY PEOPLE SO QUICKLY?
THE CONGRESSWOMAN HAS A READY
ANSWER FOR THAT AS SHE DOES
MOST THINGS.
SHE SAID REPUBLICANS WORKING IN
CONCERT WITH FOX NEWS, QUOTE,
DEMONIZE ANYONE WHO ISN'T A
WHITE MALE.
IT'S BIGOTRY PURE AND SIMPLE.
THEY MAY LOOK LIKE BAD POLL
NUMBERS.
WHAT THEY REALLY ARE IS RACISM.
IT'S POSSIBLE YOU'LL STOP AT
THIS EXPLANATION.
IT IS PREDICTABLE AND
SELF-SERVING AND UNSUPPORTED BY
EVIDENCE.
SKEPTICISM IS A FAIR RESPONSE.
LET'S GO DEEPER FOR A SECOND.
WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS NOT SIMPLY
A CYNICAL EXCUSE FOR PERSONAL
FAILINGS ONE WE'VE HEARD A
THOUSAND TIMES, RACISM.
WHAT OCASIO-CORTEZ HAS GIVEN US
INSTEAD IS A LITMUS TEST FOR
OUR SOULS.
IT IS SIMPLE.
WHEN YOU AGREE WITH ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ YOU ARE A GOOD
PERSON.
WHEN YOU DISAGREE YOU ARE NOT.
A RACIST, BIGOT, HATER AND
LOATH SOME HUMAN BEING.
PREPARE FOR THE EXAM.
WE AREN'T PROCTORING THIS TEST.
WE'RE ON TV.
WE'LL HAVE TO USE THE HONOR
SYSTEM.
WE WILL PLAY YOU A SERIES OF
CLIPS.
BE HONEST HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT
THEM.
EVERYTHING HANGS IN THE BALANCE.
FIRST WE'LL CONSIDER AOC'S
VIEWS ON CHILDREN.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE ANY AND THERE
IS A REASON FOR THAT.
SHE CARES TOO MUCH.
HER HEART IS TOO BIG.
WATCH HER EXPLAIN.
>> OUR PLANET IS GOING TO FACE
DISASTER IF WE DON'T TURN THIS
SHIP AROUND AND SO IT'S
BASICALLY LIKE THIS SCIENTIFIC
CONSENSUS THAT THE LIVES OF
CHILDREN ARE GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT AND IT DOES LEAD, I
THINK, YOUNG PEOPLE TO HAVE A
LEGITIMATE QUESTION, YOU KNOW,
SHOULD -- IS IT OKAY TO STILL
HAVE CHILDREN?
>> Tucker: IS IT OKAY TO STILL
THAT'S AOC'S QUESTION TO YOU.
IF YOU ANSWERED ARE YOU
KIDDING, OF COURSE IT'S OKAY TO
HAVE CHILDREN.
BACK OFF YOU AUTHORITARIAN
CREEP.
HOW MANY KIDS I HAVE IS NONE OF
YOUR BUSINESS.
IF YOU LOOKED AT IT THAT WAY
YOU FAILED THE TEST AND YOU'RE
A WHITE SUPREMACIST.
IF YOU PAUSED FOR A MOMENT AND
THOUGHT DEEPLY ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGED AND ACTUALLY SOME
29-YEAR-OLD MEMBER OF CONGRESS
SHOULD BE IN CHILD OF YOUR
CHILDBEARING DECISIONS,
CONGRATULATIONS, YOU PASSED.
YOU ARE NOT A RACIST AT ALL.
ON TO NUMBER TWO.
THIS ONE IS ABOUT FOOD.
>> MY TWITTER MENTIONS I GET A
LOT OF REFERENCES ABOUT COW
FARTS.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THAT?
>> YES.
YOU HAVE TO ADDRESS FACTORY
FARMING.
MAYBE WE SHOULDN'T BE EATING A
HAMBURGER FOR BREAKFAST, LUNCH
AND DINNER.
>> Tucker: THE QUESTION IS HOW
MANY HAMBURGERS SHOULD YOU BE
ALLOWED TO EAT IN THE COURSE OF
A DAY.
TWO POSSIBLE ANSWERS.
THE FIRST IS HUH?
WHAT KIND OF QUESTION IS THAT?
ISN'T THIS AMERICA?
HEY, STOP EATING OFF MY PLATE.
THAT UNFORTUNATELY IS THE
RACIST ANSWER.
THE ONE THAT BILL CONNOR WOULD
HAVE GIVEN IF HE WERE ALIVE.
THE CORRECT ANSWER IS I WILL
EAT EXACTLY AS MANY HAMBURGERS
AS OCASIO-CORTEZ ALLOWS ME TO
EAT AND BE GRATEFUL FOR THEM.
IF THAT WAS YOUR RESPONSE.
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU, YOU ARE
A GOOD PERSON.
NOW TO NUMBER THREE.
THIS ONE IS ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
>> WOMEN AND CHILDREN TRYING TO
COME HERE WITH NOTHING BUT THE
SHIRTS ON THEIR BACK TO CREATE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE FOR
THIS NATION ARE ACTING MORE IN
AMERICAN TRADITION THAN THIS
PRESIDENT IS RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: THE QUESTION IS WHO
IS MORE AMERICAN, ACTUAL
AMERICANS OR FOREIGNERS WHO
SPIT ON OUR CUSTOMS AND MOCK
OUR LAWS BY SNEAKING INTO OUR
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY AND CALLING
US RACIST IF WE TRY TO MAKE
THEM LEAVE?
THIS IS A TOUGH ONE.
KEEP THING.
TIME'S UP.
THE ANSWER IS ILLEGAL ALIENS
ARE THE REAL AMERICANS, DID YOU.
IF YOU DOUBTED THAT FOR A
SECOND, PLEASE HATE YOURSELF.
YOU DESERVE IT.
NOW FOR THE FINAL QUESTION ON
OUR TEST.
THIS ONE IS THE DAILY DOUBLE.
SEE HOW YOU DO.
>> CRITICISMS OF YOU IS YOUR
MATH IS FUZZY.
THE "WASHINGTON POST" AWARDED
YOU FOUR PIN OAK YOSEMITE.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT BEING PRECISELY
FACTUALLY AND SEMANTICALLY
CORRECT THAN BEING MORALLY
RIGHT.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE WHO STILL CARES ABOUT
FACTS?
ABOUT NUMBERS AND EVIDENCE AND
PHYSICAL REALITY?
IT'S 2019, MAN, PHYSICS IS JUST
A PREFERENCE.
IF YOU PERSIST IN BEING
FACTUALLY CORRECT AND CONTINUE
TO READ BOOKS AND SPEAK IN
COMPLETE SENTENCES, PLEASE KNOW
THAT YOU ARE COMMITTING RACISM.